what was your
recruitment process and training process
and things you could speak to
in in the cia
as i was leaving the air force
all that was on my mind i don't know
what you were like at 27 but i was a
total [ __ ] at 27. i'm not much better
now at 42 but yeah you owe me
but i would say make it yeah but i was
like i just wanted to be anything other
than a military officer so i was
actually in the process of applying to
the peace corps
through this thing called the internet
which was still fairly rudimentary in
2007.
i had a computer lab that we went to and
it had 10 computers in it you had to log
in and log out and slow internet and
everything else but anyways i was
filling out an online application
to go work in the us peace corps i
wanted to grow my hair out
i wanted to stop wearing shoes that were
shiny i wanted to meet a hippie chick
and have hippie babies in the wild
teaching nigerian children how to read
so that was the path i was going down
and as i filled in all of my details
there came this page that popped up and
it was this blinking red page and it
said stop here
you may qualify for other government
positions
if you're willing to put your
application on hold for 72 hours that
gives us a chance to reach out to you so
again 27 year old [ __ ] i was like
sure
i'll put myself on hold if i might
qualify for other government
opportunities and then about a day later
i got a phone call from an
almost unlisted number it just said 703.
which was very strange to see on my flip
phone at the time just one 703 area code
and i picked it up and and it was
it was a person
from northern virginia asking me if i
would be telling me that i was qualified
for
a position in national security and if i
would be interested they'll pay for my
ticket and fly me up to to langley
virginia they didn't say cia they said
langley i put 101 together and i was
like maybe this is
how cool is this yeah or maybe this is
all make-believe and this is totally
fake so either way it doesn't hurt me at
all to say yes they already have my
phone number so yes yes yes and then i i
remember thinking there's no way that
happened and
this isn't real and then a day later i
got a fedex or an overnight delivery of
an airplane ticket and a hotel
reservation and a rental car reservation
and then i just kept doing the next
thing
which i found out later on is a form of
control you just do the next thing that
they tell you to do
and then before i knew it i was
interviewing in a nondescript building
with an with a person who only told me
their first name
uh for position with the national
clandestine service so you never really
got a chance to think about it because
there's a small steps along the way and
it kind of just leads you
and your maybe your personalities such
that
that's an adventure it's an adventure
and it you don't because it's one step
at a time you don't necessarily see the
negative consequences of the adventure
you don't think about any of that you're
just stepping on
stepping into the adventure and it's
easy there's no work involved somebody
else is doing all the work telling me
where to be and when it's a lot like
basic training in the military anybody
who's ever been through basic training
will tell you they hated the first few
days and then by the end it was really
comforting because you just did what you
were told they told you when to eat they
made the decision of what to eat then
you just you marched when they told you
to march shine your shoes when they told
you to shine your shoes human beings
love
being told what to do
what about the training process
um
for for for beco becoming a covert cia
agent yeah so
uh so the interview process
is yeah the interview process too was
that how rigorous was that it was it was
very rigorous that was where it became
difficult
everything up to the first interview was
easy but there's three interviews
and some people are lucky enough to have
four or five interviews if something
goes wrong or something goes awry with
the first few interviews
and again this might be dated from what
i went through but uh
but during the interview process is when
they start they do your psychological
evaluations they do your
they do
um
personality assessments they do skills
assessments
they'll start sending you back to your
wherever you're living
with assignments not
not intel assignments but actual like
homework assignments
write an essay about three parts of the
world that you think will be most
impacted in the next three to five years
or you know prioritize the top three
strategic priorities for the united
states and
you know put it into 250 words or 2 500
words and whatever else double spaced in
this font yada yada like super specific
stuff it's kind of stressful
but it's just like going back to college
again so you go through all of those
acts and then you submit this stuff to
some po box that
doesn't have anybody's ever gonna
respond to you and then you hope you
just send it into the ether
and you hope that you hope that you sent
it right you hope that you wrote right
well enough you hope that your
assessment was right
whatever else it might be and then
eventually get another phone call that
says hey we received your package you've
been moved to the next level of uh
interview and now we need you to go to
this other nondescript building and this
other nondescript city and then you
start meeting
you start
you start uh sitting in waiting rooms
with other groups of people who are at
the same phase of interview with you
which were some of the coolest
experiences that i remember still one of
my best friends to this day who i don't
get to talk to because he's still
undercover
is a guy i met during those interview
processes and i was like oh we met and i
saw what he was wearing he saw what i
was wearing
i was medially connected and you like
the people there close more like we
immediately judge each other because
we're all untrained right so he looked
at me and he was like
brown dude with crazy hair and i was
wearing dude i was dressed like a total
ass i was dressed in like a a clubbing
shirt yeah i don't know why i thought
it'd be a good idea to go to ci
interview in like a clubbing shirt with
my buttons unbuttoned down to here yeah
um and he was like yeah you were really
after we got in he was like yeah dude
you were always really cool to talk to
but i was like
there's no way that idiot's getting in
and i remember looking at him being like
dude you were just another white guy in
a black suit yeah they're not looking
for you but here you are yeah so it's
just those kinds of things were so
interesting because we were totally
wrong about what cia was looking for
until you're in you have no idea what
they're looking for um and you're just
uh you're just shooting in the dark did
they have you do like a lie detector
test yes it's called a polygraph
polygraph
how effective just interesting for our
previous discussion how effective are
those polygraphs are really interesting
so one of the things that people don't
understand about polygraphs is that
polygraphs aren't meant to detect a lie
like they're called a lie detector yeah
but they're not actually meant to detect
a lie they're built to detect variants
from your physiological baseline so
they're essentially meant to identify
sensitivities to certain types of
questions and then as they identify a
sensitivity to a question it gives the
interviewer an additional piece of
information to direct the next round of
questions
so then from there they can kind of see
how sensitive you are to a certain level
of questions and your sensitivity could
be a sign of dishonesty but it could
also be a sign of
vulnerability
so the interrogator themselves the
interviewer themselves they're the one
that have to make the
the judgment call as to which one it is
which is why you might see multiple in
interviewers over the course of multiple
polygraphs
but that's really what they're all about
so
i mean outside of they're extremely
uncomfortable like
they're mentally uncomfortable but then
there's also you've gotta you sit on a
pad because the pad is supposed to be
able to tell like your body movements
but also like your sphincter
contractions or whatever so you're
sitting on this pad you're plugged in
you're strapped in you're tied up and it
takes so much time to get in there and
then they start asking you questions
baseline questions at first and then
other questions from there and you're
just answering the best you can and you
never know what they're seeing and you
don't know what they're doing and it's
really hard not to get anxious of that
anyways
and they the whole time monitoring the
the readings yeah from like a big
they've got multiple screens and they've
got just it's all information
superiority they have information
superiority you're the idiot looking
away from them or looking sideways of
them
and trying not to move because you're
afraid that if you like have gas or if
you move a little bit it's going to vary
you from your baseline yeah and the
whole time you're worried your heart's
racing and your blood pressure is
increasing which is a variance from
baseline yeah so yeah that means it's
it's an interesting art or your baseline
correct maybe there's some people that
are just chilling the whole time and
that's their baseline right right but
that's what they're doing they're
establishing basically i mean i guess
that means the polygraph is uh
is a
is a skill that you develop absolutely
to do it well so when people talk about
beating a lie detector it's not that
they're telling an effective lie that's
not hard it's not hard to tell a lie
to an interviewer
what then the interview doesn't care if
you're being honest or not honest about
a topic what they're looking for is
sensitivity
if they see no sensitivity
that's a big sign for them that's a big
sign that you're probably a pathological
liar
if you show sensitivity to
many things then that's a sign that
you're probably an anxious person and
they can still reset their baseline
because they can tell how your anxiety
is increasing
you know in 15-minute increments it's
it's a unique skill i mean a really good
polygrapher is a is immensely valuable
but the uh yeah it's the misnomers the
misconceptions about polygraphs are vast
you also mentioned personality tests
that's really interesting so how how
effective a personality test
one for the hiring process but also for
understanding a human being so
personality is extremely important for
understanding human being and i would
say that there's a thousand different
ways of looking at personality the only
one that i count with any with any
significance is the mbti and the mbti is
what all the leading spy agencies around
the world use as well
well that's kind of interesting to hear
oh yeah there's been criticisms of that
kind of test there have been criticisms
for a long time yeah and you think
there's value absolutely absolutely and
here's there's a few reasons why right
so first mbti makes the claim that your
core personality doesn't change
over time uh and that's how it's that's
how it's calibrated and one of the big
arguments is that people say that your
personality can change over time
now what i in my experience the mbti is
exactly correct you can your core
personality does not change because your
core personality is is defined as your
personality when all resources are
removed
so essentially your emergency mode your
dire conditions that is your core
personality we can all act a little more
extroverted we can all you know be a
little more empathetic when we have tons
of time and money and patience
when you strip away all that time money
and patience how empathetic are you
how
how much do you like being around other
people how much do you like being alone
do you make judgments or do you do you
analyze information
that's what's so powerful about mbti is
it's talking about what people are like
when you strip away resources and then
because it's so consistent it's also
only four codes it's super easy to be
able to assess a human being
through a dialogue through a series of
conversations to be able to hone in with
high accuracy
what is there for code
four letter code there's only 16 options
and it becomes extremely valuable is it
perfectly precise and does everybody do
it the same i mean those things are the
answers to those are no but is it
operationally useful
in a short period of time that is a
resoundingly powerful yes
yeah i just i i only know i think the
first letter is the introvert and
extroverted right uh
i i i've taken the test before just like
a crude version of the test and that's
the same problem you have with iq tests
yeah there's the right
uh thorough way of doing it and then
there's like fun internet way
and uh
i do you mind sharing what your
uh
personality um my type index yes i'm an
entp that's an extrovert intuitor
perceiver
thinker ent thinker p perceiver my wife
is an isfj
which is the polar opposite of me e i'm
extroverted she's introverted i'm an
intuiter she's a censor
uh
i'm a thinker she's a feeler i'm a
perceiver she's a judger is there good
science on like uh
long-term successful relationships in
terms of the dynamics of that the 16 i
wonder if there's good data on this i
don't i don't think there's a lot of
good data in personalities writ large
yeah because there's not a lot of money
to be made in personality testing but i
would say that there's
that with
with experience
with a good mbti test with a good paid
test a 400 500 question test
once you understand your own code and
then you're you're taught how to assess
the code of others
with those two things kind of combined
because then you have experience and
learning
uh it's
it becomes very useful and you can have
high confidence in this in the
conclusions that you reach about
people's professions
about people's relationships with family
about people's relationships
professionally people's capabilities to
deal with stress
how people will perform
when pushed outside of their comfort
zones
really really powerful useful stuff in
corporate world and in the espionage
world so in terms of compressed
representation of another human being
you can't do much better than those four
letters i don't believe you can do much
better in my experience i have not seen
anything better
yeah it is kind of
it's uh difficult to realize that there
is a core personality or the degree
that's true it seems to be true it's
even more difficult to realize that
there is a stable
at least the science so a stable
consistent intelligence
unfortunately
you know the g factor that they call
that uh if you do a barrage of iq test
that's going to um
consistently represent that g factor and
we're all born with that we can't fix it
yeah that defines so much of who we are
it's sad
i don't see it as sad because it's for
me
the faster you learn it the faster you
learn what your own
sort of
natural strengths and weaknesses are
the faster you get to stop wasting time
yeah
on things that you're never going to be
good at and you get to double down on
the things that you're already naturally
skilled or interested in so there is a
there's always a silver lining to a
cloud but i know now that i will never
be a ballerina
or a ballerina i know that i'll never be
an artist i'll never be a musician i'll
never be any of those things and when i
was 18 that might have made me sad but
now at 42 i'm like well [ __ ] awesome i
can go be something else
good instead of always being bad you're
not gonna be a ballerina oh let me know
because i'm not graceful
and you you've you've you've learned
this three years of experience yeah
exactly well i don't know if there's an
mbti equivalent for the for grace of
movement i think it's called s sensor oh
yeah because a sensor is someone who's
able to interact with the world around
them through their five senses very
effectively
like if you talk to dancers dancers can
actually feel the grace in all of their
muscles they know what position their
finger is in i don't have any idea i
don't know what position my feet are in
right now i'd have to look to make sure
i actually feel the floor right yeah i
definitely have
oh that's good to know so i don't
you know i'm not a dancer but i do have
that
you're a musician man like well the
music to be able to plug the guitar sure
yeah that's true that there is that
physical component but i think
deeper because there's a technical
aspect to that
that's just like um
it's less about feel but i do know
jiu-jitsu you know and grappling i've
done all my life
i don't
you know there's some people who are
clumsy and they drop stuff all the time
they run into stuff
i don't i don't first of all i don't
know how that happens but to me i just
have an awareness of stuff like if
there's a spiritual orientation yeah
like
like i know that there's a small object
i have to step over and i have a good
sense of that it's so it's so
interesting yeah you're just like born
with letters my wife is brilliant and
she still walks into doors yeah
i mean she'll walk in a doorway she'll
bang her knee on the same wall that's
been there for the last 50 years it's
it's uh for some reason really hilarious
so it's good
you